people need the voice and even right now  what I'm doing or how God is using me  I'm showing where our voices are being  muted there's  professors that are actually intelligent  actually have multiple degrees that have  been canceled  from their schools  and they don't have a music industry or  a fan base or shoe design or a smoking  hot ex-wife to complain about they've  just got the truth of what they saw and  what they dedicated to this country and  to education that has been muted by  schools that have been taken over with  an agenda and so you're you want the  brightest Minds to be these professors  and then you mute them and they have  nowhere to go and you might get a guy  now that went from being someone's  favorite Professor to he's working at  Starbucks like like he was back at  school or like he was back in high  school  so even if that voice is about anger and  Hate  it still deserves to be heard  yeah it deserves to be heard and we  deserve to ask why